the stage is now set for a council
parliament showdown
the point of contention the drawing up
of the 2015 budget
meps have rejected the cuts tabled by
member states
stating that a budget slash of 2.1
billion euros is out of the question
a conciliation procedure is now to be
opened to break the impasse
foreign
the european semester is a system aimed
at coordinating the economic and
budgetary policy of eurozone countries
the european council identifies the eu's
key challenges
member states then draw up the policy
direction to follow to relaunch growth
but member states are applying a mere 10
to 15 percent of these recommendations
meps argue this is too low and call for
more democratic recommendations
what way out is there for the besieged
town of kobane which in the last two
months
has become the symbol of the war against
the so-called islamic state
mep's debated in plenary
others argue turkey is the key to the
solution they're calling for the country
to do more in the fight against the
islamic state